marcus strowman's been real good for the
match including a victory against the
padres
last sunday at petco park where six and
two-thirds innings
did not allow an earned run strowman's
era 241
grounds this one right side diving is
alonso he throws wildly to first and
by the covering pitcher strowman and
reaching at first base will be tommy
pham
well he was well over to second base to
make that diving play
and then the bad throw to strollman and
fam will reach it's rule to base it
and strowman now will deal with trent
grisham the return of grisham for the
friars certainly good news
ground ball could be two the flip on
guillory
lingard with the turn picked out by
alonso and they turned the 4-6-3
double play a little far away for a
backhand
but he makes the nice execute executes
it well
and they turn two and that's strowman's
game joe musgrove on the mound for the
padres
joe who has been one of the padres more
consistent pitchers this year gets an
opportunity to go against this mets team
seventh pitch of this opening at baton
it hits vr
and he'll go to first base so musgrove
came inside with a fastball on owen two
and vr is aboard melindor who took
musgrove deep
in his start last saturday and he drives
this one out to right center field back
goes grisham looking up at the wall it's
out of here
lindor against this time a 2-1 homer in
the mets of an instant two-nothing lead
here's the fast bat i've been waiting to
see from lindor
he's been very long with the swing and
if you're along with your swing on a guy
that pulls as hard as musgrave you're
not gonna catch up
one down and dom smith will be the
better
man turns on this they want to catch it
first by hosmer
up into the air hosmer makes the grab at
first base look at haas get up on this
play
fastball in on the hands eyes having to
go up the ladder
we go to the second inning with marcus
strowman on the mound
fernando tatis junior and tatispow tips
one for strength three
he struck out three times last night
he's another one of those low ball
hitters doesn't like the ball
myers is a board with a two out single
which will bring up jay cronenworth
in there strike three called he got him
with a fastball knee-high
side retired two strikeouts for strowman
no runs to hit one left
with a lead-off single to begin things
here in the second inning so two on
jonathan vr muskrobe deals and the
curveball is swung on and missed strike
three
back-to-back case for joey works around
the lead single here in the second
inning
and keeps the mets from adding to their
lead go to the third in new york
victor caratini leads off the third
against marcus strowman
caratini hits it sharply giorgi with a
beautiful stop
luis ski or may welcome back a magician
with a glove
a sliding backhanded scoop popped up
quickly
and retired caratini with a strong throw
oh and two strikes to grisham with two
down and fam at first
swinging a miss strike three got in on
grisham's hands
when they cut fastball over the inner
third grisham strikes out strowman
spanned
four in the first three innings we'll go
to the bottom of the third
now pete alonso flied to the warning
track in left field his first time up
did he go oh he's gonna be called out
anyway jeff nelson didn't even check
said he offered the home plate umpire
and alonso strikes out that's the third
k for musgrove two down here in the
third inning
two outs five in a row retired now by
muscarovin brings up dominic smith
a swing and a miss by smith as he was
fooled badly in the first one two three
inning of the day for joe musgrove
a couple of k's here in the third two
nothing meds as we go to the fourth as
he leads off this fourth inning with a
single and now the padres have had
a hit in each inning so far in this game
against strowman fernando tatis junior
the battery struck out his first time
one-two coming struck him out
strowman through the kitchen sink at
tatis and he gets him for a second time
fifth strikeout in the series for tatis
there's the grip the slider
and now hosmer who grounded out to
second bases first time up
chopper right side guillermo has got it
throws to lindor for one over to alonzo
two
a double play four six three exactly
what strowman was looking for
will go to the bottom of the fourth his
first three ball count
of the day for joe muscaro a full count
here to the lead off hitter for the
match james mccann and a swing and a
miss got him to chase that slider that
was never a strike
and that is strikeout number five for
muskrobe but it's now three in a row for
joe
seven in a row retired by muskrobe
swing and a miss and pilar strikes out
4ks in a row for joe musgrove
one and two the pitch to guillerme on
the outside corner strike three called
musgrove strikes out the side here in
the fourth and he has now paid five
consecutive met batters
head to the fifth inning in new york
marcus strowman has enjoyed it so far
today doing what he does 11 straight
scoreless innings all against the padres
strike three call got him looking at the
two seamer
and it came over the outside corner and
that's six strikeouts for strowman
actually it came over the middle one out
here's jake cronin worth it swung on and
missed strike three
buried that cutter down and end seven
strikeouts for strowman
base it for fam and he is three for
three on the day
one now one on and here is trent grisham
all for two today
there goes fam at first pitches outside
for a ball
and fan is safe at second base state on
the bag
good jump by fam throw is high really
the only
question was did fam come off the bag i
think he hooks it with this back foot
here
3-2 coming to grisham swung on him
missed strike three
got him with a sinker when strowman's
needed an out today
he's either been able to throw a double
play ball or get a big strikeout
eighth strikeout there and with two gone
manny machado coming up
swinging a heart hit grounded a third
backhanded by vr straightens
throws to first in time again machado
jogging down to first base
and that retires the side now the mets
with a chance to increase this two to
nothing lead
lindor good speed at third alonzo at
first now dom smith who can use a big
hit will be next
gets the first pitch breaking ball hits
it on the ground to second
cronenworth gets he out of second
titista first not in time as the run
comes home
to make it three nothing new york it was
a very slow developing play
and dom able to beat the rap at first
three to nothing new york one out can a
former white sox
one of their big free agent targets this
winter grounds it right to cronenworth
little flip to fernando
on to first in plenty of time and an
inning ending double play
marcus strowman back to the mount for
the seventh to face fernando tatis now
with a three-nothing lead
oh one to tatis is hit in the air deep
to left field
absolutely smashed it's gonna go
into the third deck at citi field in new
york
number 18 for fernando tied again for
the national league lead
and the padres are on the board three to
one mets here in the seventh
my oh my was that ball touched so stolen
gets through six in the third he goes
six in his plus for his seventh straight
start
first time in his career he's ever done
it so now lugo
who got two outs last night back for
more today now manny machado is coming
up representing the tying run
swung on him his strike three side
retired
lugo gets him with a slider strikes out
three in the eighth inning
and the padres aren't done in the eighth
top of the bounty winner jonathan vr
leads off against johnson
that's smack to deep right field headed
for the coca-cola coin
it's out of hand the
jonathan vr plants one in the coca-cola
corner
he basically walked about halfway to
first base then started his home run
trump
as we are it's his sixth home run of the
year
and the mets have a four to one lead and
at the end of eight
permits four the padres won and thus the
padres are down to their final
out nets can clinch the season series
from san diego with a win today
hits one off the glove of diaz lindor
with the pickup
tight on throw in the ball game is over
lindor closes it out by readjusting his
body
and turning the one six three put out
the mitts gets six and a third
solid innings from marcus strowman and
they've beaten the padres two in a row
to start this home stand